>> The speakers that I did
not introduce in the morning,
I don't think he also
needs introduction
as Professor Raj
Reddy mentioned,
does binding work in
Computer Vision Machine
Learning et cetera,
so I'll let Professor Jawahar
take the stage. Thanks.
>> Thank you for
the opportunity.
So I'll try to give
a quick overview of
what is happening in
the computer vision area
in recent past
and hinting at the major
trends in this space.
However, when I tried
to summarize this,
I found that it is
not very easy to
compile or put together
the major themes in this space,
so I might have missed a
lot of things that
are happening,
but let me give you an attempt.
So Computer Vision as a task,
like as an image
understanding task,
has been evolving over
many years, decades,
and the focus has been
on understanding
the content of it,
in terms of what is a scene,
what are the objects presented,
where are the objects presented,
how are they placed.
Who is close to what,
a set of questions that
you can infer out of it,
so this has been the broad focus
of Computer Vision
for many years,
or at least a dream of
Computer Vision researchers
and practitioners
for many years.
So now, to give you
the background of how
this community has evolved,
the concern has always
like given an image
how to interpret.
What is in it? How do I
know whether my understanding
of the image is good?
Whether my processing results
of the image is good,
so that we are happy with
the success or failure
of that algorithm.
At least we know if it
is succeeding or not.
So we'll take
a history lesson from
the low-level vision
or mid-level vision
where anybody who has ever tried
to understand the process image,
one of the first thing
that we all learn
to do is to detect edges,
detect with
the Sobel operators or
the small tiny mass that we all
learn to write programs
to detect edges.
How, if you look at
an image like this,
an natural image like this,
where if you want to
detect an edge or a contour
or separate an object
the task is very difficult.
And very often, very subjective.
So one of the first attempt in
this space has
been to understand
the subjectivity by the help of
multiple human experts
saying what's an object,
what's an edge,
what's a contour,
and then using this
as a benchmark,
trying to see how
algorithms perform,
and how to characterize
the algorithm
with the performance metric
which we can compare and
see the progress over years.
And we see that, over years,
we had approached
closer and closer to
human limits of understanding
the object contour,
and we are now
reasonably good at processing
some of these tasks.
But the modern Computer
Vision said there's
mostly on a higher level task.
So in general, this sort of
an attempt, gives
us few lessons.
One, we need a formal
definition of the task,
and a realistic dataset
with annotation on
which we can evaluate
the performance,
and measure that can quantify
the performance basically.
Algorithms that can use
this annotated data.
And on top of it,
how a community
can use this data
and see the progress over years.
So, this has been
the primary driving force behind
the Computer Vision research in
the last couple of
decades seriously.
So in the higher level task,
where the task is usually not
just detecting the extent of
the objects or where
they are present or
understanding the properties
of the pixels or regions,
it has been mostly recognition.
Really, attempts on
recognition was on
objects which have
lot of presence in
natural images like
humans, human faces, text,
characters, character
recognitions and vehicles,
and understanding their poses or
positions in natural images.
So the history of
the modern Computer Vision or at
least which became
very hot in post 2000
where the task of understanding
were formally casted on
a wide variety of natural images
internet repositories of
images became very popular.
We all had our own cameras,
and we all had captured and we
found that the applications
of Computer Vision will
have to be on natural data
captured in the wild conditions.
So in these stage,
the communities started building
datasets and task navigations.
So the initial attempt of
object recognition was captured,
natural object is captured,
images of the objects,
it may be in a focused manner.
And then, when it came
to Pascal animates that,
the late 2005 and onwards.
We were capturing images or
processing images
which are more and more
wild than naturally captured
in their natural settings.
And the past became more,
and also vary more and
more formally defined,
initially the task was to
say, what is this object?
Then it became like tell
me where is this object in
this image and how is it placed?
Third level, we
went to the level
of tell me which pixels
are on this image itself,
so the task became, even
if it's a bike,
which bike it is.
The fine-grained
understanding of
the visual content in
terms of the pixels,
were all, in terms
of the properties,
like which bike or
which make of is it,
this level of task got formally
stated and the
appropriate datasets
for this task came
into the literature.
And this was the
major phase where the,
the formal definitions and
improvements in
the community was measured.
The Pascal, for example,
which started in 2005; by 2012,
they found that, okay,
this task will have to move
forward with a new set of tasks.
The industry at the same time
the natural datasets
collected with the ImageNet,
one of the largest datasets
available of images which
had extremely large number
of categories of images,
and the number of examples,
became also the one of
the very important player
in the emergence of
the Deep Learning,
because the turning point
in this history has been
this AlexNet which appeared in
2012 where the task on image,
the classification,
the performance
of the previous era like
the last five years we have been
engaging by like improvements
by one percentage,
half percentage over years.
While in 2012, a completely
different approach which is
an end-to-end trading off
a deep neural network give
a significant improvement
of close to 10 percentage.
This attracted the
researchers, and this made,
this convinced
the larger wider community
that Deep Learning
is robust and this is usable
for a variety of tasks,
and people can get into this
and the rest is possibly,
still modern Computer Vision.
So, if you look at the
historical developments of SIFT,
and the previous
Deep Learning era,
the performance was 25.
And from 2012 onwards,
like very very very fast,
we came down in
the error rates and became
quite comparable to
the human error rates
in say, three, four years time.
A number of deep,
deeper and deeper architectures
came with better and
better learning algorithms,
better and better methods
to design architectures
which are more compact,
efficient, and this is
where the post Deep Learning
era, the architectures mode.
Now, from a pure Computer
Vision point of view,
there are lot of
other concerns in terms of,
what do we mean by
understanding images?
And how do we
represent the images?
The features or
the representation
of the image has been very,
very fundamental issue in
the image understanding
or image analysis space.
So if you would like
to have features or
representations
which are superior,
and the previous era,
previous to deep learning,
we have been doing
mostly histogram-based features,
borrowing ideas
from bag-of-words,
and a number of variations
of it which connects
to the IR community, signal
processing community.
Now, since the image
classification problem
is solved for
a specific ImageNet task,
we ask the natural question
that, "Okay look,
what does it mean to the
larger Computer Vision space?"
So, the answer is,
the features that we
compute by trading
the ImageNet are generic.
This give us a new hope that,
a network which is trained
to do a certain task in
the image space is fully
useful for a number
of other tasks.
You train the neural network or
deep learning algorithm
for a separate task.
However, and their
process you build a set of
representations which
are widely useful
for a wide variety of
other Computer Vision tasks.
So you have
a neural network here.
We just trained on
the specific task
of classification, however,
if you stop at some layer and
make a representation that
is useful for
recognizing a new object,
or a new class, or
a new type of visual data.
Now, you can reuse
this and you can
also do refine these features.
You can improve this features
with the help of
transfer learning,
or you can adapt
the knowledge that is trained
in one domain of the one domain,
or one category of images,
or one type of images,
to a new type with
relative ease.
And people in fact have looked
into how generic or
critical is this.
The amount of data
into the first domain.
It is found that,
with a small amount of
pre-training itself,
you can build
solutions which can
be very useful for a new task.
So, in this case,
a Deep Neural Network
which was trained
on ImageNet is completely
acceptable to a new task
of same classification,
which is completely
a new set of images,
new task definition itself.
And naturally, the concern or
the positive result of
seeing a generic features,
also resulted in curiosity
of what these neural
networks learn,
and found that
the learned concepts are- If
you try to open the deep
neural network and look
at what neural network
learns over these layers.
It is interesting to see
that the initial layers of
these deep neural networks are
learning features,
which are very generic.
Like small edges or corners,
and the later layers were
learning semantically
richer concepts,
like objects or object parts.
And this gave us
explanation of what how
these features are generic,
and how do you transfer
these features from one space
to the another space.
Then came the question
that, "Okay look,
we have been seeing
only the success
of supervised learning.
Can we do something
beyond that?"
Creating annotated data for
various task is tedious.
And how do we avoid it?
So the vision community
had the answer to this was,
use the larger context,
and learn in this way
so that later
on or the features that
you learn in this process
is useful for other tasks.
To give an example,
if you have an image,
and you want to guess,
you chop or you mask
a certain region of the image
and say, what it will be.
So similar to the ideas
from Word2vec.
Where you are given
a sentence and remove
word and ask you to predict
the word given the context.
Similarly, given
the rest of the image,
can you predict what could
be there in this patch?
And if you're able
to do this task,
then the features that you
are learning, is also generic.
So this sort of ideas of
learning from surrounding text,
learning from previous frames,
learning from parallel
data, for example,
the case of Wikipedia pages,
like Wikipedia images and text,
so the text topic models
can act as learning
signal or supervisory signal
to the image
classification task.
And so, this entire class
of algorithms which
does not really use
the fully supervised learning,
which use innovate unsupervised
or self-supervised learning,
or learning from itself
by harvesting
the supervisory signal
within it became very popular.
Now, we had seen
the features that
are useful for missions
for processing.
What about humans?
If you want to have representations
that are more useful,
one way to look at this is,
building representations
with are human
understandable and which human
should be able to manipulate.
So this was attempted with
the help of by connecting to
language and in this era
that there is lot
of connection between
vision and language first.
So, instead of understanding
the image as a classification,
the newer tasks like captioning.
Given an image can you
write a sentence about it?
Or given an image can you
write a number of phrases
corresponding to what this cat
is doing in this image?
Or the relationship
between objects?
Like cat sits on something.
So this level of phrases or
the corrections are first.
So, in general, just looked
at a set of supervised methods,
where you have an image
and a set of sentences,
and you'd like to learn
the relationship between them,
and learn models so that you
can generate a number of,
a caption or human
understandable description
by composing the understanding
of the objects and
their relationships.
So, these are few more examples,
where we are able to generate
the human-like captions for
the corresponding images.
So, here you can see a number of
such and the compositional
descriptions appearing here,
where objects and
their surroundings
are connected together
to come up with phrases,
or captions, and different
resolutions in the space.
So this space has been
flooded with atoms in 2015,
'16's time, with a number
of architectures,
which used convolutional neural
networks and recurrent
neural networks.
Beyond that, then
the next question is,
like if you have such images,
can you interact
with such images?
Can you do the dialogs
based on these images?
Can you understand what
is there in this image,
and can you ask relevant
questions and get answers?
Can you have continuous
dialog with them?
A number of open task
in the space came out.
And what is a common
sense knowledge,
how that is represented,
and how that can be
extracted out of it?
Another threading
which is parallely
happening was,
generating images.
One way to look at generation
is a goal where you know that,
okay, you're able
to generate, if
you're understanding is good.
Well, that's one way to
look at the generation.
So, in this case
the popular gaps,
one with that evades us
are generated with the help of
a degenerative model
from the scratch.
And you have
a discriminative network
which is basically
asking the question,
"Can I separate a fake or
an artificially generated image
from the natural image?"
There are two modules.
The first module is
generating an image,
it's a trainable module,
which is generating an image.
The second one is
trying to separate an
artificially generated one from
the naturally generated one.
Now, so these two modules
compete each other
and they play a game
and learn to perform better over
time and learn to
generate images,
which are highly natural.
So, these are
few examples of images
that are generated
automatically.
These are not
realistic bedrooms.
These are not real people
whose faces are being shown,
but they are generated
automatically with
a generative model.
This generation also provides us
mechanism for represent
building networks,
which has plenty
other side roles
in terms of building better
representations, et cetera.
So, this is another example
of such generation
where if you have a set video,
can you predict the next frame?
Is it possible for you to
predict the next frame and then
see how that frame is like?
This tells us more that our
understanding of where
the objects will move,
where what'll happen in the next
frame and how that will have to
be visualized in
the pixel space itself.
And also, like if you are
given more specific information,
can you generate images,
which are more closer
to the description or
the information that is
given as a prior information.
So, there are examples
like generating
birds which are
of specific type,
which are sitting
in specific form,
et cetera, are
generated in this way.
So, we have control over
the generation process
in a much larger pack.
And finally, in the space
of image analysis,
the low-level vision or
a number of task has been
formulated as an image
2 image transformation.
And in this space, it
has also changed a lot
in the last year
or last few years.
To share a few examples,
how do you generate
natural-looking images,
like colorization?
Or, how do you convert
an image into a new style or
a new painting style
automatically?
Or, how do you generate
a high resolution image?
Or, how do you create a 3D model
from the 2D images directly.
In many of these cases,
our prior understanding of this,
how this has to be done is
encoded into the neural network
with the help of huge amount
of data that it see.
So, let me summarize.
So, the computer vision
has been seeing
a steady progress towards
looking at harder
and harder tasks.
Moving from two class
to tons of classes,
to thousands of classes to
ten thousands of classes,
and also providing structure
to the output space in terms of
the fine grain representations
of the classes.
In the detection case like face,
the classical example of face
detection that we all use on
our mobile phones to
deformable objects and
more complex objects,
pixel-level segmentations,
final understanding of
the image into
multiple labels and regions.
Detections, bringing
semantics by
connecting to the language,
nouns, verbs, and
various semantic structures,
interacting with visual data.
Image-to-Image translation,
capability to synthesize.
This is what the community is
moving in the recent years.
That's all. Thank you.
>> We can probably take
one or two quick questions
since you're doing short talks.
Yeah, there's a question here.
I'll take this one first.
>> So, you gave
a nice overview of
the different techniques
used in that computer vision
over the past decade
and in the past as well.
But you talked primarily about
the deep learning
aspect as such.
On a broader level,
there are many works,
which actually were used in
the computer vision communities
specifically talking
about pixel labeling,
probabilistic graphical
models have been
used a lot in the past.
So, what is your opinion
on that whether?
So, there are some
recent works which have
tried to combine the two things
like deep learning model
followed by a probabilistic
graphical model.
So, what is
your opinion on that?
Will it be totally data-driven
or the older techniques like
the probabilistic graphical
models have a role to play
for better
understanding especially
in the pixel labeling context?
>> I believe they have.
I think the next years will
see much larger connection
between the classical
machine learning
with deep learning or
the popularly known as
deep learning as
a black box that
maybe many of us
possibly complain,
or so, I think the comment
also originates from that.
So, I think there's
a larger connection of
a classical machine
learning with
the deep learning is
good if it happens so.
>> We can take probably
one more quick question there.
>> My question is
about the text to image part,
the slide that you had shown.
One part in order
to achieve that,
one part is of course parsing
and understanding the text,
and then mapping it to
the image, how is that done?
What are the elements?
What are the basic
elements on which
you work to generate the image?
>> So, this is presently
being done with what is
called the GANs, it's a network,
which is able to generate
images from scratch. Yeah.
>> Okay. Maybe one more
question, last one, yeah.
>> Like, who manage solving
simultaneously many problems?
Like face, I am
visualizing the face,
then face detection,
emotion detection,
then mood detection,
as well as the beauty
and ugliness of face.
This means many kind
of things at a time.
So, if I want to make
CNN architecture,
so different network we have to
make for detecting
these tasks so,
how to combine
these all networks?
>> I think there
are a lot of process
happening on multitask learning
or more relevant things
for that purpose.
Maybe, I think that
the machine learning
session tomorrow
will answer that.
All CNNs can be trained
for that purpose.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> Okay, so I think with that,
we'll probably end this talk.
Thank you Professor Jawahar.
As always, it's been a pleasure.
>> Thank you.